today recreational boating is more
popular than ever and we're headed to a
factory where they're keeping up with
the demand
the company is searay inven or tennessee
they're one of the largest boat
manufacturers in the world turning out a
whopping 10,000 boats every year today
we're going to see how the company
manufactures one of the two most popular
sport modes the Sun down at just over 26
feet it carries up to 12 people can
reach speeds of up to 55 miles per hour
and is outfitted with everything from a
stereo system to a wet bar
Marshall welcome to Ceres Teleco Lake
facility the factories about 230,000
square feet we employ about 630 people
this is utterly fantastic building any
boat begins with constructing its
exterior or the hull and in the case of
most fiberglass boats such as the Sun
Deck that means using a high-quality
mould like this
workers fill the mold with a liquid gel
that hardens into the shape of the hull
then they add additional materials such
as fiberglass and foam beams for
reinforcement finally after the boat
sets for a few hours they lift the
finished haul out of the mold in other
words they build the hull from the
outside in
but before they fill the mold with gel
workers first grease the mold surface
with a special wax so the hardened Hall
will pop out easily then they use air
hoses to remove any bubbles and dirt
particles from the wax otherwise these
impurities would Mar the smooth and
shiny surface of the hull
then a forklift pushes the mold into the
gel booth where to 750 pound robots away
it's their job to cover the molds with
an exterior gel coating which will
harden and become the holes outer shell
so the mold is moved in and what's gonna
happen here the robotic arm did you see
we're going to start spraying detail
coat on the robotic sprayers glide back
and forth for 20 minutes
covering the mold with a layer of
quick-setting polyester resin this makes
the whole durable and virtually
impenetrable to the water the gel coat
also contains a pigment which gives the
hall its color the bottom part of this
hall will be white in just how thick are
those layers of gel coat when finished
that's one of C rays trade secrets why
do we need robots doing this what's the
advantage they give us you're more
consistent on the right pattern better
quality no once the bottom dries workers
remove the plastic that covers the top
of the green mold later don't paint this
green section blue all right so this
will make the bottom part of the whole
of the boat yes where does the the deck
come from but thank you sprayed on our
other set of robots focus on us here and
he goes through the same process this is
what the deck looks like after the
robots sprayed it with this same gel
coat as the hall but something doesn't
look quite right does it that's because
the mold it's sitting in is upside down
later the deck will be popped out of the
mold and flipped 180 degrees before
being lowered into the Hall